les amis est ce qu'un jour un grand sage
n'a pas dit il faut apprendre à rire de
soi-même avant de rire des autres
il l'a dit et aujourd'hui nous allons
illustrer ce propos en commençant par
prendre une voie naturelle et en 17 mois
rôle vous souvenez vous de vendredi
dernier quand vous regardez des vidéos
de nous-mêmes qui datait de cinq ans
dans les bassins regarde bien il ya eu
quelques malaises quelques moments
d'incompréhension et ben je vous ai
donné sur twitter de faire un best of
des malaises et 2 mai vide parce que
ouais ça arrive même aux meilleurs
pourquoi je fais des abonnés et
quelqu'un a trouvé dix de ces moments et
les amis dans une vidéo et nous allons
la découvrir ensemble
je suis prêt grospatapouf qui nous
présente sa avec la musique la plus
vieille du 21e siècle blake de merde
alors ça y en a dans toutes les vidéos
bon donc là on est sur une spéciale
d'alsace région natale de sébastien loeb
sont absents à droite l'avenant un peu
plus bas on parle pas des aides que tu
as
ça commence bien tout d'abord je
présente les excuses à sébastien loeb
qui à cause de cette blague a pris la
décision d'arrêter de conduire des
voitures 20 ça va c'est une blague de
merde mais ça c'est pas trop ma les ans
ça passe y en a où toutes les vidéos
j'étais à bordères en faisant aux deux
nuls omnium et au final on adore les
limites vachement bien j'ai bien
apprécié la cohésion de groupe
dans le donjon avec norman qui est très
important en coulisses on exactement en
est la raison dans sa prière gaming une
cohésion de groupe qui prête ses proches
mais on apprécie arrêtés auraient de se
balader sa bonne gestion gère ma chaîne
youtube numéro 3 réactions très chaud
loua [ __ ] la salle est autre chose
qu'une blague lâchant que ça va être dur
et ça ça c'est pour la vie dans les
biens non le mec là même les gars sont
dans le top est bizarre c'est toi mais
vrai problème les glaçons
chacun veut j'avoue là on est sur une
échelle non sur un escabeau on est sur
un escabeau la génétique et l'ambiance
en disant ça je vais pulvériser a des
fois j'aimerais juste fair and on a bien
joué et norman a tenu à faire le mec se
prend pas mal numéro cinq gros bide est
le 4ème ténue la sortie par le feu
c'est un gars me ferait du bruit ouais
j'ai pris un jeu qui tue mais non mais
je voulais pas laisser cet homme vit d
imaginer une seconde si je n'avais pas
crié à ce moment là si je n'avais pas
sauvé et vic finalement y lit que tu
devais te pousse vers sont les dix
prochaines vidéos pour la pub elle lui
aussi ses anecdotes gênante
ok ce que j'ai fait je veux passer une
petite soirée delahaye tranquillement la
perche aux hipsters
je pense que ça va être pas mal apple a
eu lieu et on a remarqué un truc c'est
que je lui arrive au téton donc c'est à
une balle n'a je pense que j'essayais de
meubler méjean encore plus que quand tu
viens des ménages et a dopé ses
métaphores de main basse sur cette scène
de théâtre bizarre
ouais c'est sûr un [ __ ] de live on a
vu un gage un truc comme ça il fallait
que reproduise une scène au théâtre de
merde avec yann et qu'on soit c'est un
vieux bijoux tout ça devant une caméra
bien allumés et bien en direct sur
internet malades numéro huit petites
humiliations j'espère que c'est vraiment
une petite sportive de haut niveau et
squeeze au milieu mais c'est les
pointures savoir que david lui soit
proposé de s'asseoir sur la basilica le
moment le million il le fallait
moi je me suis assis sur les genoux
david luiz mais là j'avoue je suis là
avec mon tout petit corps entre les deux
titans que sont david luiz et thiago
silva jeu comme ça alors ouais ouais je
ferme ma gueule et j'accepte de
m'asseoir sur les genoux du papa way
malaise numéro 9 tentatives d'imitation
spectacle et parler mais avoir un petit
peu denses et moi je suis pas faire
c'est karima attend une tétreault allait
bien tu as eu l'oeil fait mal à ceux là
il fait mal
j'aurais dû dire non et pour les besoins
du live pour vous je les fais je me
souviens de ce moment on ne sait pas
dire non et john o'shea des jeux lui
faire plaisir avec ces petites karima je
sais pas la sphère ne dit jamais oui
pour faire plaisir parce que des relais
cause des corps ce sera pour votre
gueule oui on en faire une vidéo qui
mène même pas à me sortir de cette
situation [ __ ] tu vois par contiennent
c'est là qu'on reconnaît les vrais amis
ce qu'ils font aux comme c'était bien
alors c'était de la grosse merde je vous
emmerde d'entretien et le soutien le
kartman âge effet la surcouche que j'ai
mis la deuxième couche jamais j'étais
une petite pile électrique à l'époque un
numéro dix tentatives de blagues
pourries non assumé mes mecs si je passe
par la choucroute
le coup de matraque de coups de matraque
pas très drôle si c'est pas super sympa
et c'est bien pourquoi je vous sens on
sait le reste on s'est croisé des ondes
ouais je l'invite c'est encore la faute
ce qui se passe je voulais me faire
plaisir je vous les mettez quelqu'un que
je sait imiter ce que j'ai marché adore
invité jean claude van damme et il adore
quand je limite en train d'imiter jean
claude van damme imitation ception mais
les réactions de mes amis n'ont pas été
celles escomptées on agit mais qui
pousse à jouer avec sa langue pour gérer
le malaise cyprien mon binôme toujours
aussi content de mes déjà la chine qui
rigole parce que il a pitié de moi hugo
tout seul qui est moins seule que moi
pour le coup et yann qui se cachent les
yeux devant ce supplice merci les gars
c'est le plaisir j'appelle avec vous
tous elle a écouté les amis c'est court
faut croire que j'ai pas trop trop vide
laissé derrières années mais intense est
maligne au cerveau a plus que d'habitude
je trouvais ça important de clore un
petit peu cette série de vidéos ont
réagi à des malaises la débine en
réagissant à nos propres vies des
propres moments de malaise et en avait
deux ou trois qui étaient surpuissant la
seule jeune rachid en fait faut plus que
je côtoie jardin chez justin je devais
être bloquée de partout je ne veux plus
qu'on se voit ça démarre deux doigts du
cul et là je fais des bides attendre
deux ans pour une autre compilation
encore plus douloureuse j'en suis sûr
aller vers ça vous regarde et on sortait
une prochaine vidéo forte vous bien tu
as tout le monde glisse